okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at find geometric proof a
new
capability for 12.2 that
is for generating proof structures
from um
geometric scenes now i mean my first
question here is how does this
correspond
to um
uh find equation of proof
yes well obviously the logical system is
quite different
uh but i i think the argument structure
we
attempted to model on on that
okay right and the form of proof object
yep it tries to have most of the same
properties
okay all right um and the appearance is
obviously different and this doesn't
look like it's been graphic designed
no and actually it'd be better if you
went through the agenda for
example okay mostly okay okay all right
find the length here let me make this a
little bigger
find the length of the base of a
triangle given its area an altitude so
here's a geometric scene
with a line euclidean distance a planar
angle 90 degrees blah blah blah
okay find geometric proof okay so first
question is what is this doing relative
to okay so if i take that scene
and i say random instance
of that scene i'm gonna get a triangle
right
hello it's a little weird
okay run it again
does it not have a heuristic for
deciding when it's reasonable
why does it take so long it's um
and also those look kind of ugly
well we have a separate meeting to
discuss right
well the sin seems to be spitting out
degenerate stuff
um there's sort of refer
to uh to try to draw
um you know draw good
uh non-degenerate polygons
and such but that does run up into
making sure
run against uh in a sense making sure
that um you know there's full generality
allowed so um it's
it's kind of a fine line you have to
walk to uh
to uh yeah what is even it the area
of state oh that's probably the problem
it should be area but try yeah that's uh
that's
um that should be triangle y zx i would
assume
at least for the um yeah yeah
that's a good point
so it's like that one it should be able
to handle okay
all right fine okay so now
i'm totally confused here so this is a
scene
and can't i just ask
it okay so that's a random instance of a
scene but here i'm
trying what is this proof what's that a
proof of it's a blank
there that that's the that's the right
that's the statement that you want it to
prove
and it's you know you you you could tell
that
what well i mean why don't i tell it the
euclidean distance is equal to some
particular number
well you could do that too but if this
is
if you don't if the question is
find the euclidean distance that the
finds it
and you know tells you why
but that's not the proof go ahead go
ahead
well sometimes you're you want to put a
question mark numeric q on the end of it
because you want to
make sure that you get the first answer
which is
a number
yeah i don't understand that statement
but right if you already
if you already know if you already know
the answer yes you can put in
the the the answer right so but this is
just being nice to you and saying well
try to prove a statement of the form
this euclidean distance is equal to
something
okay okay all right okay
fine so this is the analog of show steps
for geometry do we have any hope of
being able to enter the inputs in
wolfram alpha
not as text
but what about us drawings
on the discussion okay
i noticed that noah is here and i know
he has drawing tools
that work in the in the desktop front
end at least
we we discussed with you on
okay yeah we have a meeting on this
tomorrow okay
okay
so what is this now so okay so so then
okay so then this is a proof written in
some human readable form
that doesn't seem very computable what
what happens if i just say
um let's find the proof here okay so
let's say i say
pf of proof graph
so the embedding of the proof graph
unfortunately changed recently in the
prototype build
so it should just have straight lines
and it should be a layered graph okay
can i just pull the graph out and let me
just do that then
yeah i'm not sure why the proof graph is
giving us
something with tabs which i can't read
can you maybe increase the
what does it have you know on one more
level i don't think it'll help
but yeah i can um
well maybe it does yeah facts tooltips
no labels oh
it gives you different choices that that
seems
excessive right i don't think we do that
for normal proof objects do we no we do
although it's an interesting idea
jonathan i don't know whether you would
like to comment on that
um we could support it it never occurred
to me
yeah oh my goodness freaking sake
okay um
i believe if you paste it into an older
version it will
look better
okay so these are givens this is
interesting so how does this relate
i could sort of imagine what happens if
we re re
reorient this i mean if we say here
vertex coordinates goes to automatic
right
that's probably what i want need to say
whatever whatever
um can we make sure this is reported as
bug is this a bug in the graft layout
stuff for something else i haven't
determined that yet
well who knows okay okay in any case
okay so this is now showing the
dependency
now is it ever going to do anything
non-trivial
in this in this graph
sure it's a graph with a source and a
sink
and any kind of branching directional
graph
it can happen any anything can happen is
what you're saying
uh yeah of these kind of uh
proof graphs that you're familiar with
um
what's a bug
the fact that there's a node there that
doesn't seem to
come from anywhere well it's also got a
plane geometry synthetic geometry proof
stump wrapper
yeah there's a few things that are not
quite right in this recent build i'm
sorry
okay but fundamentally i mean like like
all this you know empirical metamathics
and euclid that i've been doing this
should be drawing the same kind of
graphs is that right
that that say to prove this theorem
you need to have each one of these nodes
as a theorem is that true
yes
so to prove this theorem you
are contributing from so so they're also
presumably axioms of euclidean geometry
which are not being shown
as so onto each edge you are applying
certain what are you applying onto that
edge to make it happen
in other words a previous theorem how
does it how does it
insert itself into this picture
um not a given theorem it just means
something that's previously proved
yeah something that's in euclid's
elements for example
um well well see i don't think it's
anywhere right this is a
synthetic prover right it's i don't
think it's anywhere near that
constructive right so yeah so the edges
are generally
you know uh um
the postulates that's the word i'm
looking for sorry
are generally you know postulates or
maybe well-known
theorems from the elements um
and they sort of take you from one sort
of
fact to another fact well what you're
saying is
this is this is a computational prover
so to speak
as opposed to a a formalistic prover i
mean a formalistic approval would build
up from the axioms and prove everything
this is something where you're saying i
already know a lot of geometry
now i'm going to use what i know to
establish some results
correct it's very heuristic
right and it's designed to try to look
like
a two-column proof you would see in
uh geometry
it's what humans would do not from first
principles
right okay so so can i can i get that
for this pf chords thing
the graph no no not the graph the the
the
written out what what how do i get that
yeah the um
[Music]
proof notebook camel case
by the way i don't know where this
design comes from but obviously it needs
work
right exactly
i was going to warn you that there are
still a lot of rough edges in the code
this is just one of
them so i mean this here should just be
a gray number it should
not say no at the top um
obviously this this um yeah i mean the
fonts the colors etc etc etc are all
kind of bizarre um
so i mean this is essentially we're
synthesizing text
much like we do in show steps for
something like
you know calculus or algebra or
something is that correct
yeah what does this mean by seven
distance
ae by algebra on
so just the generic way we say we used
algebra
hopefully someday we'll have the uh the
the wolfram alpha show steps to explain
this a little better
but this is just dividing by seven
you know i could see that but i don't
know what the
i'm trying to figure out whether there's
a there's a little blot on my screen or
well no no
it moves as i scroll so that's not a dot
on my screen
that's a that's a dot somewhere else
okay i thought it's just a piece of dirt
on my screen
um the uh
yeah and also i don't understand this
distance a b don't we have a
symbol for that i mean i mean there's
just so many things wrong with this
okay so yeah we had talked about this
and i i should have mentioned before
that
all the formatting of the of the
geometric statements
is going to be totally replaced with
what ian has now built
so the the text yeah i'm working on that
what has he built is that a traditional
form version of this or something or
what it's not exactly traditional form
but yes it
it's more traditional for me looking and
so
um right although for
going to use it here i i mean the
question is what ian belt is
not interpretable so
you know if somebody copies out from
that notebook and pastes it in it won't
evaluate anything
so if that's a bad thing we need to
rethink how
ian stuff works
well okay so proof function doesn't
exist here
actually i did build one that works but
it's
we decided i shouldn't spend time on it
because it's
kind of a silly thing uh yeah but
there are no system functions to do this
functionality
right so it would just be a bizarre a
bunch of bizarre internal context things
to
right there there it just didn't make
any sense
all right so big picture here we would
like to be able to generate from all
from alpha
kind of euclid style after 2 000 years
we want to be able to generate
automatically these kinds of proofs
is that the basic point i mean so i can
pick a random proposition in euclid
and i can type it in or i can somehow
draw it
and then it will then we can generate
that proof is that is that the idea
yeah okay
so so let me just understand the
different steps here so one step is i've
got to be able to draw the original
thing
right so i'm drawing something like this
is that correct
um you can draw it first um
there is a drawing tool no no i
understand but
but not realistically people are not
going to at the wolfram alpha level
right
they're not going to enter something
like that right
nor are they going to enter kind of a a
verbal description that will sound like
you know
some real estate plat survey that says
you know go
this distance in this direction and just
take this angle and so on and so on and
so on
right well although they could
conceivably type in
something like you know let a be a point
let be
in that abb points let you know consider
let you know the line a b blah blah blah
right without without some kind of auto
completion mechanism i
i can't imagine we'll be able to make
that work in other words unless we go
into a mode where you're typing
structured text that just seems
completely implausible to me
because these things will be quite long
and there'll be many many ways to get
lost
i guess yeah does the structured text is
something we have discussed
there um steve is suggesting publishing
euclid with this set of notebooks
you are we have in fact should we show
just as a
just to show that we actually have
anybody want to show the computable
euclid
thing under development um
somebody sends me a link i'll put it up
there yes
we are on that subject yeah we're on
that idea
um but
um okay so
uh what was i what was i saying here so
so i mean so okay let's just
understand the workflow the workflow is
somebody draws this diagram
we have the ability they put this line
here they have it they click something
that says that's a right angle
okay i mean is that is that what we're
planning or is that
i mean you know that seems plausible and
then they're going to ask
and then what do they want to do they're
going to you know it's like what we had
done
years ago with um you know you give an
image and then you ask questions about
that image
that right now i mean the other thing
that people are going to do because
unfortunately
today's students he says because the
older always criticizing the young
um you know especially greeks
i think it's the human condition has
been the same for a very long time
in any case but but um uh
the um uh they're they're um
um you know people will just take
pictures
of geometry questions what do we do in
that case
i mean we've had a number of experiments
trying to do natural diagram
understanding
they've been it's been pretty difficult
what are we imagining is going to happen
in that case
i don't know that this is the right set
of people to ask right i mean that's a
heavy-duty image processing
right but i'm just trying to understand
the complete workflow here so the
workflow is
somebody draws a diagram and they ask
questions about it is that correct
if we're talking about alpha right i
mean we also imagine mathematically
users might be interested in this
in which case they can just type in a
geometric scene
or once we have somebody to finish
working on the drawing
tools for geometric scene they could
draw a geometric scene
right okay but but realistically what
kind of computation
would involve um you know
you know when you write these kinds of
things okay so we've got a bunch of
primitives here
which are you know when i'm trying to
solve an actual geometry problem okay
i've got my
you know my piano and i'm trying to get
it through these doorways
right is it realistic for me to
you know under what circumstances can i
really turn it into stuff like this
the latter one not because it has
basically one free parameter the
precision
okay like you're moving things it's a
totally different board game
okay all right but so what class of
things can i enter
i mean clearly euclid thought it was
interesting although famously
you know told people um you know i just
read a story
okay uh it was by
an assistant of isaac newton's
apparently who had worked with isaac
newton for five years
and said the only time he saw old
isaac laugh was when somebody had um
he had given somebody a copy of euclid
and the person said
uh asked him what is this good for
apparently then he laughed so
you can read that any way you want but
um uh but okay so the question here is
you know what you know beyond
kind of you could in you know beyond the
sort of uh
uh the exercise of of doing proofs and
so on
what you know what are the industrial
uses of this
do we understand that what are the
things where
um so for the drawing there's um
you know geometric constraint solvers
are a big thing in in cad drawing and
i've actually been approached by
some people at the previous tech
conferences
about um indeed
right so indeed that's a real thing
right now for find geometric proof right
i think
we're in the land of you know school
of school not industry right right
but for the geometric scenes
that's something um uh
where um
you know that's something where we could
imagine much more sophisticated things
where we're trying to
give constraints and so on here okay but
we're now
let's go back to proofs so
you know one of the things that we have
learned from from find equational proof
is that you know we originally produced
fine equation proof
in an attempt to make somewhat
computable what had otherwise just been
a narrative story of proof
what has happened more recently um
is that you know we've now been actually
starting to compute with those proofs
and we've discovered that we did pretty
good job of making that well
i i don't know jonathan might want to
comment on this i would say the proof
graph
which we originally made just for
decorative purposes has turned out to be
a really very useful thing
um and whether it was intentional or
subconscious
you know make some nice connections with
multi-way stuff and things as you've
been saying
right but so for example the proof data
set
i would say is less convincingly useful
at this time
i mean in other words you know just to
remind ourselves what we get in that
case because i'm trying to understand
i'm trying to think ahead you know how
are we going to use these geometric
uh proofs so for instance i mean
if i were to um
just pull up
you know random example here
um
let's say
what do i have here here i have some
random example
oh you don't want to use chef's axioms
they're huge
use axiomatic theory yeah okay fine no
i'm just i'm just joking i'm just
i'm just it's just snobbery about
axiomatic systems for bullying algebra
that's what that's it's it's um uh okay
so anyway so we get the proof data set
here
and it's a big hairy mess and the
question is
what would we imagine using this for
because so far we've never used it for
anything
really other than just looking at it
and that only rarely and by the way
i would like to comment that a general
design thing is that these things here
are essentially representations of the
application of rules
and i'm convinced that we need a const a
construct called replacement
that means how a rule is applied
that is if we say um
uh and i'm just trying to understand
that because i'm trying to understand it
in these
in this case as well right so this is go
ahead
the the substitution lemmas are those
the critical polymers are a bit
different right
they're really like two replacements and
a statement of most general unification
yeah i mean the fact that we have those
two kinds of things here is i think
somewhat arbitrary
um i i don't completely know but anyway
so so here
i'm just concerned what is the analog of
proof data set do we have a proof
data set here there is and there's a
computable proof
uh proof data set
i think yeah
okay so that has a lemma okay that's
nice so that has something which is in
the same format
so basically you're generating lemmas
here
if i say pf chords
well not very exciting glamors and
that's a bug
right is that a bug yes shouldn't be
exposed
but what is it i mean it's just it's
just something which was a wrapper
yeah it's a constructed radius is what
it is
but how should we represent that
that's been a discussion but um what i'm
doing now is just using uh
c for constants and p for points with a
integer index
so these have to be uniquified objects
right is that something that you run
into jonathan and your proof thing you
have i think x1 x2
right right so we have generated
variables and we use
um essentially de bruyne notation for
indexing them that's the scheme we've
been using
image context do they live
uh i think they're the equational logic
backtick oh
i thought this was a no yeah that's a
that's a
that's a kind of a no-no um
i may be wrong i can't it's it's been
ages since we designed this
it seems to be just in system context
yes it's yet worse i mean listen the
story of generated variables
i mean by the way of course in our
physics project
we are all basically generated variables
you know the whole freaking structure of
the universe is a bunch of
generated variables produced by you know
what we can think of as lambda
expressions that have their inners
hanging out
um so but we don't have a great way to
do this i mean you know
the only ways we have to do this are
using unique which is pretty horrible
um i mean i don't think we have a way to
do this
i mean so for the the drawing the
geometric scene
i have to generate variables and i can't
use unique because i need the
generated parameters if you run the the
if you run random instance on the same
scene
multiple times it needs to have the same
generated parameters so i
basically use capital c of and then a
bunch of strings
oh yeah but so this is analogous to what
happens in a differential equation
where we generate you know these x ones
are similar to the c's that we get from
solving the differential equation right
right
c's or case
yeah but i mean those things are
that thing there is in fact
in reality that is
that right it's a print form of that so
we could imagine
having a similar kind of thing which has
some print form
that is a formal variable i mean we've
had the same issue in in axiomatic proof
of anaxomatic theorem you know axiomatic
theory where we end up with these kinds
of things right
because we want these to be to be
variables that can't have
values but you can't subscript them
but you can but then it's no longer what
you wanted probably
what are you saying there you mean
exactly you don't want subscript formula
a comma one
you want formal subscript a1 yes
right
boy right i mean
well unless we made all of the axiomatic
theory stuff just ignore subscript
in other words unless we made it so that
this construct
would be always treated as a as a symbol
which i don't think would be crazy
you know treat that as a i think that's
dangerous because you can make
assignments to subscript
right formal a is protected but
subscript of
formula one is not i know but but
you know we we gotta we gotta draw a
line somewhere i think here i mean in
other words
so look i mean what we've got here okay
we've got generated variables of various
kinds okay so this generated variable
here
is i mean arguably
what about giving c multiple arguments
where or maybe even an option that says
how it formats
then we
you mean we actually have c's in here
really
really are c's but there is like uh they
uh
appearance goes to raw okay whatever you
want
that's truly scary right well so so do
do something like
integrate x uh
comma x comma y
with this option i assume uh oh
yes generated parameters goes to
automatic
i think
or probably c
oh dude i guess ducey
um right
so that's you to generate a c sub 2
rather than to just try and encrust
c sub 1. is that the point you're making
well i i
i was i was i was i
was making a bad point but yes in this
case these are
right these constants are sort of not
constants
right they're they're so one argument
one possibility would be that we have a
thing called
formal or formal variable we were just
formal just say formal
and then it has things like a one or
whatever it is
right and that essentially what this
means is it's something that you can't
assign to
i but you can't also solve really
quickly we could make solve deal with
that
we could make this in the functions that
matter
we could make this be and i mean if we
did that
that would have the advantage um
i mean we could get rid of for
formatting purposes we'd get rid of all
those nasty dots and so on
i mean i i think we're going to wind up
with something like this
because i i think you know and and if we
did that
we can have a generated formal object
here
what disadvantages might have is
frequently say in mathematical
identities
you don't want them to be evaluated
but this one i would just need
evaluation to behave properly
no it could just have formatting i see
it properly
properly i mean i don't know why we
didn't do it this way
in axiomatic theory maybe jonathan
remembers
i mean so we have discussed this type of
thing other times so
in my opinion the main problem here is
that
in my opinion there is no way of
avoiding unique because if you have a
formula with
with dummy variables and you copy it
from some part of the notebook and put
it somewhere else
that formula may have again format a1
and then we are screwed again
and another thing is like for
mathematical function identities
uh we use them as arguments of pure
function but they must be symbols they
can't be compounds
oh gosh yes well i mean we could fix
that you know look at some level we have
to bite the bullet and really solve this
but i mean i go ahead my my suggestion
for this and this is the thing i've used
in exact
is that i use dollar variables
internally but before
those variables get printed they are
replaced by nice variables
and so the users keep seeing nice
variables but they're never collisions
because internally it's all unique
yeah but that doesn't solve your problem
with with the the chameleonic problem
back in snp i had these crazy things
called chameleonic symbols
which had the property that every time
they were used they would have a
different name
right and what's bad with that
it was unbelievably confusing and
disastrous but other than that it was
fine
i mean it was just utterly obscure
because you would get
things go ahead so imagine that
internally you have
a dollar one eight dollar a million
eight dollar two million
but before they get printed they always
get printed abc
and you use them again abc and you copy
that you put it somewhere else
you put two of them they will be a b c d
e f
so you mean they look as if they collide
but they don't really collide
they never collide because they in in in
a session
each of these variables is always unique
it's only when they are going to be
printed
right but you can never type them in
right because exactly because these
things are generated
if you pre i mean you can't you can
print a
and then the system is intelligent
enough to realize that when
when printing the a dollar one cannot be
replaced by a
because a is already used
right well that means you must have some
outer rapper that knows to do this
replacing exactly what i do is that i do
dollar prep print it
equals some function that handles
everything
yeah i don't think that's a general
solution
right it's general solution but it's a
solution you need to be aware of
because you see a and internally it's a
dollar a million
right so i mean one thing to remember is
we could use a letter like form
not dollar as our convention for how we
you know we could even have something
you know we could have
something that looks a little bit better
than a dollar
something or other i mean it's never
going to look great but we could at
least have a different character there
if we really want to do it that way but
i mean i i think
you know i don't understand this i don't
understand this i mean
basically if we're going to use it here
so in these formulas
the x1 in this formula is different from
the x1 in this formula right they have
nothing to do with each other
right and and the the point is what
happens if
i want to combine both formulas so i
copy one i copy the other one
and put them together yeah and then your
toast
by the way i i should say that you know
the the solution that jose used in exact
is essentially what we're doing here i
mean
if you assign x1 to something it won't
change the internal behavior of find
equation or proof it will just change
the way that the proof data set
is typeset
sorry so that again sorry so exactly as
jose said
within find equation of proof we're
doing the the exact uh you know
solution where uh everything is
uniquified
within the actual algorithm it's only
when it's returned that we
send things back to pretty variables so
if you say if you rerun that proof
but you set you know pre you set global
x1 to be
you know four or something it will still
run it will work
fine it's the only thing that will
change is the way that the proof data
set type sets
it will avoid that or not yeah i think
i think it will i think well let's do
the experiment i think he's saying
that if if you just set x you know x one
equal to four
and then reevaluate the proof data set
sub value right
reevaluate find equation or proof and
you'll see it doesn't change the out it
still
proves the thing correctly nothing about
the behavior will change oh sure but
then the proof data set i'll have
garbage
yeah yes okay yes no i understand so
your point is that
it's only in the construction of the
proof data set that you insert these
things
right right yeah i i want to make it
clear that we're not yeah
the the the internal algorithm is not at
the mercy of the global context
right look we have the same problem and
you know the fact that i had this
problem 40 years ago in smp
is kind of telling um you know we have
this problem of formal variables
that have to get renamed when that
whenever they're used
we should just solve this problem once
and for all either by
you know i mean essentially
the dollar variables thing is unique you
know is using unique
right and um
so the issue is right so what
what the geometry folk are doing is
different right they're actually
embedding the information in
[Music]
of of what that point represents into it
but
okay so i've got a crazy suggestion okay
what if we pick a character
okay i'm gonna pick a wolf
okay what if that thing
just formats as x in other words
there's a letter like form in the symbol
name
that is basically a sing a signal to the
pretty printer that says
just don't show everything after that
character
but for the geometry you won't say
something
radius one and radius two so row one
whole two with
subscript just wouldn't work well okay
fine fine i'm gonna i'm gonna be even
more hacky
okay i'm gonna be even more hacky i'm
gonna put a
i mean in other words we're basically
using the fact that we don't want to
avoid it being a symbol
right so i'm gonna say i could do this i
could say this
blah blah blah blah blah so in other
words i could have two pieces i could
have
a piece where it stays as a symbol name
it's a symbol
it walks like a symbol it talks like a
symbol etc
but it has that subscript burnt into it
and this simply formats as x sub
1 and it ignores this last part
that's pretty dangerous i mean the
assumption that you know symbols
type set as plain strings is hardwired
in a lot of places in the system
uh so i mean not every symbol look
let me point out as we deal with you
know what about a
a symbol with a hebrew characters in its
name right it's not a
when you say plain string right left to
right right to left etc etc etc
yes but it's still but two boxes of it
produce something that is string q
and you're pretty talking about this
you know giving something
piece of this yes i see that that i
agree that that might be an issue
um i mean i i don't understand why we
don't just
you know i mean if if all we want is
something that looks pretty
then why not just stick it in an
interpretation
and so the underlying it's whatever it
is and then you make it look however the
hell you want
right and when you're talking as if we
didn't solve this problem 24 years ago
okay well what are you proposing i mean
so so let's say axiomatic theory for
example
right so instead of replacing all of
those things with
you know a literal symbol x1 it uh
constructs
interpretation of you know
whatever display it wants comma the
underlying variable
isn't that the other way around what
order arguments does it talk about uh
the the interpretation should be at the
end
i see right right right right okay so so
interpret it as
x okay right so this could be subscript
of
x one but the interpretation
x dollar one two three four five
okay all right so but let's say
that that's not good enough though i
mean if axiomatic theory
returns a thing that is of this form it
will be indigestible to computer
computational functions won't it no it's
interpreted as x
dollar two three four five blah blah
blah
okay so if i say this thing if i say
this thing
let's make a table of those
that's probably not the best way to do
it but let's do it this way anyway
okay
well that's pretty good behavior
but now the problem is yeah here's the
problem let's say we take axiomatic
let's say we take this what is that now
is that
yeah so i can't take those as as you
know
modulated balls for example right yes i
mean they're
i mean unless we made that work which we
perhaps could
i mean that's that could be the lesser
of the evils
to make interpretive to make module work
with interpretation
in other words to allow module of
that x1
right i guess we're we're
um
right well see the thing is you you you
literally
typed in the interpretation rather than
copying it right
so if you had copied that out
then it would have been interpreted as x
dollar
two three blah blah blah blah blah right
so if you take that
percent 74 i think it is or can't quite
read
uh 600 and something but whatever okay
the
674 yeah right and you make a table of
that
table of percent 674. no not of percent
674.
take the output
i mean copy the output yes
x x so you're saying
okay so if i were to ever copy if i saw
the output from axiomatic theory am i
able to ever copy it i would get this
kind of garbage
well as long as you left the yes if you
left things
unadorned what do you mean by an adult
right as long as you know as long as
things didn't
um right if you did something that
returned it
unevaluated yes
right i mean this is something you could
use in module right now
right you could do a little bit i
understand that but it looks
extremely ugly it lost its annotation
right
look the fact is at some point here
there is some heavy lifting that has to
be done
we've got module variables we've got
pattern variables we intended for
version
two maybe three um it was a one
it was a 14-hour design review
attempting to put subscripts into
pattern variables
and eventually we had it almost
implemented in version
three i think and we pulled it out at
the last minute
because there was a bunch of semantics
that was just incomprehensible
and what we had there was basically so
what that was
among other things was symbols whose
names
so for example let's do this let's say
i say i take this thing how do i make
that into a
string with that form i just say you
know what i'm asking if i say quotes
that
right okay so now i say symbol
of that what
what what what what what what
yeah you can't do that that's not a
valid oh that's right that's what we
tried to do for version three
there is probably code somewhere that
tried to do that that tried to allow a
symbol
whose name is an arbitrary string
including a string with inline uh
formatting yeah
there was i i've seen vague traces of
that code but it's no
you know when fixing bugs and in
make expression but it's i don't think
anywhere close to
functional or well i know that was that
was
you know that was 1990
i've probably yeah 1995.
um
right look we do have to solve this
problem
we've circled around this problem since
for nearly 30 years
we really should solve it okay um i mean
and and that will i mean going back to
this and we're going to need to wrap
this particular meeting soon
um
i'm a little concerned about this
i mean i'm a little concerned about this
functionality that is
you know it looks nice i'm just
concerned about
how we really use it for things
well i was going to you know do you see
the all
in in the first argument here
and i'm not sure what it's returning
it's returning random facts that it
knows
but is so
but is it proving multiple things i
don't understand or is it just stating
multiple
true things it just creates a long list
of true facts
until it either runs out of time or
um it's your max iterations
or it thinks it's found at all it can't
iterate we've run into two issues here
which are
you know one is the style of computing
that just says
you know essentially enumerate a
multi-way system and start producing
facts from it is not what we're used to
which is what you're doing here
effectively just find all these random
paths in the multiverse system
well it's it's kind of strategic there's
no i understand it's similar to find
instance for example which will
try and find solutions to equations but
it has no guarantee
to find all of them that's one thing
we're also dealing with the problem of
you know variables and formal variables
which we just got to solve the first
problem
for this case is maybe not so bad
because
for practical purposes there's only
finite number of things what you
at this level at least want you want
distances areas orthogonalities
uh coinciding intersections and related
things i'm not sure we should i mean the
does
right i mean find equational proof
doesn't have one argument form right
i mean i'm not convinced we should have
a one you know this is effectively a one
argument form right i don't think find
equational proof takes all
uh as the things to prove well in fact
find equational proof
that is exactly what multi-race system
does
is it just goes and just trees out all
the possible
theorems right find equational proof in
principle could take
i mean it would be typically infinite
right it could take
a quotes one argument form of the max
items option
that just says find two facts
right jonathan right the analog would be
equational multi-way system with the um
you know with the substitution numbers
critical pair letters switched on
is that is that some function in the
physics project because i've never heard
of this function
yeah it's a function of the physics
project functional repository it's a wfr
thing it also happens to be extremely
new jonathan
like less than three days old
oh dear how how how how have i missed it
i'm sorry
um
uh sandra is commenting that all these
proofs are in a sense
second second-order polynomial solving
um
is that that is a true statement right i
mean these are these are circle and
um you know second-line rule and compass
type constructions
but they're complicated they're
complicated
uh coupled you know large numbers of
coupled quadratic equations is that
correct statement
underneath it is correct but that is not
what fine geometric proof does that's
what um geometric solve
is that what we're calling it would do
this is not quite correct
yeah i mean it's which right i mean they
right they have lots of radicals in them
right so it's
it's not you know once
right so you know it's not pure
quadratic
systems okay so the question what was
the what was this fine geometric
i mean geometric solve geometric solve
is uh
that's a new function that basically no
one outside of the uh
the synthetic geometry team has looked
at yet
um the point of this function would be
um you it's you input as the first
argument a geometric scene
and then the second argument um
something you want to solve for either a
uh
you know a quantity in that scene or you
know some
just say length of between a and b
and it will try and if that
quantity you're solving for is uniquely
determined by that scene it tries to
return it
okay basically things that are
coordinate
invariant so that's synthetic that we
understand or if if if coordinates are
supplied
in the first argument the geometric
scene then it will just use those
coordinates
listen we're running out of time i have
a couple of practical points by the way
ethan on the livestream is pointing out
that
this should have a progress monitor does
it
no be nice if it did because it's going
to take it a while
okay let's let's be practical here this
is a very complicated function with a
lot of tentacles
um what are we gonna do for 12.2
i have a possible suggestion maybe we
should just
have this code and you know basically
expose it in the function repository
rather than exposing it in the core
system because i think the design of
this
i think there are many design issues
here and i don't think we're going to be
able to solve them all
and you know i think there are issues
about these formal variables there are
issues about
how we use this computably and so on i
mean
michael you have i think that's a good
idea i mean yeah and
and then to be perfectly honest the
state of the code is not such that i can
believe it can be made shippable in one
month
so so that that that sounds
you know if it's if it's just backing a
function repository function
that sounds like a much better point
starting yeah
i mean it's already useful and it may be
useful for teaching
but it might not quite have the
production and strengths we
we aim for how would you
like if you have a uh
that never mind like for a function
repository item with
you know the thousands of lines of code
no
no no no no no we shift off that yeah
right we we
ship it at in the kernel in some hidden
context
and then we have a function repository
function which basically just
maps the top level stuff to the hidden
function
what we do is say virtually everything
for from other notebooks
right or we do that in um you know or we
ship
a bunch of code in the function position
it doesn't really matter the function
repository is as much
an exposure mechanism as it is a
code repository for these kinds of
functions
um uh all right
and look we need to have a meeting about
these formal variable things this is
such a
you know i i have to say i i will tell
one little story
because i can't resist it um a few years
ago
uh i was
was looking at this big book about
lambda calculus
big thick yellow book about loudly
calculus thousand page book or whatever
it is about
indeed yes indeed who has uh
who we'll probably be talking to on on
some live stream about the physics
project in not too long but
in any case the the um um uh
i think christopher and i were looking
at this and um
uh the question was you know in all of
these years of lambda calculus right
all these things where where you're
where you're you know
uh got variable renaming and you know
lambda calculus has exactly this
variable
renaming issue as do our function
functions et cetera et cetera
like in in nearly 100 years of lambda
calculus
you would think somebody would have
solved the variable name in question
okay so you go through this whole book
it's it's a huge
mess throughout the book at the end
there's the grand climax
where it talks about variable naming and
its solutions are absolutely insane
and and utterly hacky i mean like this
de bruyne numbering thing
and so on they're all just you know
basically nobody has solved this problem
and i mean the only person who solved
this problem is the is is in a sense
sean finkel with combinators
um you know back in 1920 uh where
there simply aren't any variables the
problem with combinators is
nobody can understand what you get the
um the uh
um
anyway i think that that um um
um yeah all right
one remark so well i truly agree that
this renaming is an important one
from a practical point if you look say
comment of people
the x one something
is maybe even more important
what do you mean x one something you
mean like you see so frequently people
have a
differential equation and then make x
subscript one
as the initial condition but what they
mean
is x subscript one as something
independent of x
i see say x of zero is x one
yeah well that's that's that that is
exactly what we wanted to do in version
three with the
variables right but it's not quite the
renaming it's a slightly different
problem
no that's right it's it's look look we
could solve this problem
if we broke the idea of symbol names
being strings
being no they could still be strings but
they might have to be strings that have
more complicated display forms
that would solve the problem the problem
with that is canonicalization
that there are multiple different ways
to get something which has the same
appearance
with a string you at least imagine apart
from invisible characters and other
pathologies you imagine that you know
different
you know different strings have
different display forms and so on
um
ethan is suggesting that gpt 3
could infer informative variable names
for code transformations
yes we have tried some of these kinds of
things it is not
a bed of roses in fact it is completely
crazy
what it does um the
um yes oh there's a question here from
ethan which we might be able to answer
um about uh
update on the paclet repository and
irrelevant to this discussion but it is
moving along i believe
i think we'll probably have a review of
it quite soon um
i mean look i do want to just highlight
this point about the different style of
computing
that is the proof style of computing and
i think we're slowly understanding
kind of uh you know and that style of
computing is more the kind of prologue
logic programming
style of computing where you just state
certain constraints and then you say
what's true based on these constraints
or that's one version of it
the other version is you know uh here's
the thing that i'm trying to get to
show me the path by which you got there
and i think we
you know that's something that so far
it's actually very i would claim this is
actually really quite an interesting
thing that's coming out of the physics
project
that the a the analog of a proof
is a path like a geodesic in spacetime
and that makes us care more about paths
and therefore care more about proofs and
therefore makes us want
more to have proofs be computable things
and that's sort of leading us into this
domain where
where we really have to have a proof be
computable because this kind of thing
here
isn't right now very computable we
haven't used that you know i don't know
any functions that take the innards of
this
and um and compute with them and that's
that's the issue there
anyway very interesting stuff all right
i need to go i forgot to have lunch
today
and i am just incredibly hungry here so
and i have another meeting so
so um uh all right um
too many exciting things all right well
um uh yeah ethan is saying that these
lines should be rendered with latex
they're certainly super ugly here
they'll get a lot better um
all right great thanks guys thank you
okay